well joining us now is a former british
ambassador to russia that's andrew wood
hello to sir andrew thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
absolutely shocking news coming out of
mariopol both at the steelworks and also
uh the number of dead as a result of
what appears to be a russian targeted
strike on a theater where women and
children were sheltering
horrible
they don't care
the russians
and they lie about it anyway
i understand um
where do you think this is going to end
mr ambassador we know that
next monday i think is is a big day
isn't it it's a victory day in um
in moscow in russia and
it had been thought that by then um
putin had thought this war would be won
what do you think will happen now
well he thought he was going to win it a
long time before
but in fact he's he's losing heavily
and i think we have to realize that he
cannot win the war
in the sense of
achieving
a settled outcome
nobody in ukraine
is going to forget what he's done and
what his forces have done
and the way they have done it
that in itself is a defeat
secondly
it is apparently
the case
that he's already lost more
russian troops to death
than they lost during the
war in afghanistan
i think he's in a terrible fix in that
way
but russian propaganda is
completely
it doesn't care about the truth anyway
so presumably he will try to work up
some sort of story
probably that it's all our fault
um
but i think he's an impossible position
uh we are being told by the kremlin that
uh president putin is still open to
talks with uh president zielenski do you
believe him
well i'm sure he's open to talks with
zelensky provided zielinski agrees to
russian conditions whatever they are at
that moment
there is no
i don't think it could be any real
dialogue until
the results in
the eastern region are clear
if russia continues to lose troops at
the rate they are
then they can have talks about russia
retreating essentially
if he if he if he wins
in the sense of slaughtering more
russians
sorry that's sort of sort of more
ukrainians
[Music]
it still isn't a victory because it's
not a permanent solution to anything
we also must keep an eye on what bella
russia is up to
um we are being told that they're
conducting military drills um how much
of a threat do you think this might be
to ukraine
well if belarus was
ready to
send his troops in and mobility and
mobilize fully it would of course be an
increased threat
but the belarusians so far have been uh
extremely cautious about doing anything
and some belarusians at least have
decided to fight on behalf of the
ukrainians
so i think lukashenka has to
watch his control over his own country
which is already fragile
um
so again i think it's something which
may happen
but i do not believe it's going to be a
full-scale invasion from belarus
um just hearing from the ministry of
defence this morning saying russia will
likely seek to inflate the threat posed
by ukraine opposed to ukraine
by uh the exercises that we are hearing
about in belarussia um
and ordering to fix ukrainian forces in
the north preventing them from being
committed to the battle for donbass i
suppose that is that's a reasonable
theory isn't it
it's a reasonable theory and if it
happened of course it would be
a
a threat to to ukraine
i do not think however it will produce a
surrender
to russian conditions
or belarusian conditions
from ukraine ukrainian president
is uh
it's holding its own very very well
indeed
and it's um
revealed the fact
that the russian army and i would
believe the belarusian army as well
is of limited uh experience and skills
it's uh it's a
we all believed or most of us believe
that if the russians did invade
uh in
february
it would be quite a quick win for them
because of the numbers of troops and
because of the
idea that we all had about their
effectivity
but i think we forgot
that the russians have actually had
rather little
experience of fighting
hand-hand or between troops
what they did in syria for example is
flattened cities just as they
did flatten the cities when they will
hit war against
chechnya um
and as they
would have done it had they felt it
necessary
in in georgia
controlled and um widescale fighting has
not been their
skill
and their
effect has been very poor from that
point of view
as uh
as i understand from military and i
can't pretend i've done it myself
but it is a complex thing which they
have not
succeeded in in doing
what more do you think
britain could be doing at the moment and
indeed why do europe
i think what britain is doing at present
is
stalwart and effective
it certainly
won the affection of ukrainians
and it's also
increased britain's standing
and attitudes
in the whole of eastern
[Music]
eastern eu if you like
i was recently in
in estonia for example
and
our word had quite a lot of value to it
the idea that finland
and sweden may also join the eu
now
is uh
it's it's it's an absolutely radical
change
and a radical change for russia
i can only hope
that in the end the putin regime will
take a kind of some new realities
and um
be different
you say cautiously
yeah indeed so um mr ambassador it's
always a pleasure to speak to you thank
you for taking the time to join us on
the breakfast show on sky this morning
thank you thank you